Its time for Drew's News,
the only news that feels like baked ziti for the soul.
Oh, God, I could eat baked ziti every day.
And with me at the desk is the best co-pilot in the biz,
Rossi Ross Mathews.
Hi, everybody, hi!
(audience clapping)
Oh, and it's pasta week.
It is pasta week, my favorite week.
Your total favorite.
Happy pasta week, everybody.
Yes, I know.
And in today's noodle news, guess who?
Dolly Parton has just revealed the secret
to her mac and cheese and you're not ready for this, Ross.
I am not ready.
When I read what her secret was,
I mean, I love Dolly Parton, she can do no wrong,
but I was like,
maybe this is her first misstep ever.
"Insider" reports.
Dolly never serves mac and cheese without,
get this, fried apples.
Yeah, mm-hm, bleh.
And this unique combo platter happened by accident.
One time Dolly was just making mac and cheese,
my soul sister, and tossed in some leftover fried apples.
I've never tried that.
And she had them lying around
and she never looked back, Rossi.
Well, she wrote "Islands in the Stream"
so she had to try apples in the cheese is
what she had to do.
(audience laughing)
It makes my brain go (buzzing).
It doesn't make any sense, like apple.
Well then I thought, well people do put cheddar cheese
on their apple pie.
I've never done that.
Have you guys do that?
No.
That's a thing, people do that.
I am so excited because we have some here.
Okay, I'm gonna try if it's.
If Dolly can do it, I can do it.
Oh my God.
Dolly.
(audience laughing)
It's apple pie with cheese.
She actually has.
The mac and cheese is secondary to the apple
in the most complimentary and confident way.
I wanna say this right now on television, Dolly Parton,
I've never been more wrong in my entire life.
(audience laughing)
This is how it should be.
There's the apples are cooked down with cinnamon
and then mixed in that cheese is so delicious, you guys.
Dolly, Dolly, you did it again.
(audience clapping)
And the best news is, Ross, it's your story.
Oh.
That bowl of mac and cheese is gonna be gone
by the end of this story.
All right, everyone, less than a month after retiring
from the NFL, Tom Brady has announced his next venture.
Is he moving on to another team?
What is he doing?
No.
The "Hollywood Reporter" says Tom is taking on Hollywood.
And when the seven-time Super Bowl champ makes a play,
oh, he goes big.
He'll be producing and appearing
in a football road trip movie he helped develop called
"80 for Brady" and listen to the cast.
He's got Hollywood's biggest icons to star in it.
Lily Tomlin, Jane Fonda, Rita Moreno,
(audience clapping)
and Sally field.
That's quite a cast and they're gonna play a group
of best friends on a road trip to see the 2017 Super Bowl,
which is the one that Tom Brady came back
and beat the Falcons last minute.
Remember that Super Bowl?
And I have to say, getting Sally Field
and Tom Brady together and Jane Fonda,
this proves that prayer works, okay?
Because this is everything I've ever wanted.
You know, someone said upstairs, like speaking
of Dolly Parton, where's Dolly?
You have two thirds of the holy Trinity of "9 to 5."
You're right, you're right.
Lily Tomlin and Jane Fonda.
And I thought, (gasping) you're right, where's Dolly?
And then I found out that Dolly Parton is actually
gonna come in and do an episode of "Grace and Frankie."
Oh really?
So there is hope she will make an appearance in this.
Yes, please.
That's a great idea.
(audience clapping)
(theme music)